uh great teacher onizuka classic is a
classic and i've heard all about this
yeah i watched it all right it's weird
i've never read the manga for this i've
only watched the anime i've heard the
anime is amazing yeah the anime is
amazing but i've heard the mangas even
better the the i think the anime is i
mean it's it's good because the manga is
[ __ ] amazing yeah right that's that's
that's that's the only reason the anime
is because like he's so goddamn good you
can't mess up
because like because like okay have you
seen the i've seen the anime did you
think it came out
uh
what the anime yeah
it was like late 80s right
it came out in the year 2000
oh i'm not joking are you serious i am a
trap question i felt the track set up
when
well it feels like late 80s it feels
like late like early 90s it feels like
late early late 80s early 90s anime
adaptation it came out in the 2000s it
came out after cowboy bebop
but because like because the anime
advertising have an existential crisis
on the gto today
so i mean i think i've talked about gta
briefly before but to uh to give to give
a brief synopsis of gto it's about it's
about this teacher who is delinquent oh
he great oh he great oh yeah a great
deal he's no no no no he's not a great
teacher yet because he's just he's he's
he's uh so his name is onizuka and he's
delinquent who finds himself in a
teaching job right and let me guess let
me guess he's just
he's not a good teacher in the start but
he learns to love the kids and he wants
to help the kids so he becomes a good
teacher no actually he he wants to be
the greatest teacher in all of japan
hence the name great teacher
but uh what he he's given like a very
problematic class right
and uh yeah he's not like the greatest
teacher academically and that's part of
like that's like part of the point of
this manga is that he doesn't teach
academic lessons he teaches life lessons
and i know
i know i know i reach these kids he's
not he ain't book smart he streets
[ __ ]
kids making you sort it correctly yeah
but like if but like it's
it's a manga that i think really
affected me when i've read this as like
a teenager because
you know it sounds it it is like a
completely cheesy kind of um set up
right because you know it's just oh this
it's a teacher who reforms a problematic
classroom and teaches them life lessons
and makes them appreciate life and stuff
and yeah that's that's exactly it's it's
a it's probably
the best feel good manga i've ever read
japan loves those kinds of manga they're
like yeah there's another manga like
that called rookies i don't know if you
know that one
i don't it's like if you took gto but
you made them play baseball
and but it's like it's the exact same
like feel good vibe you have the
delinquent teacher who like teaches a
bunch of delinquents to like join a
baseball team and stuff like that yeah
exact same feel as gto is like just as
good it's just it's just really it's
it's also a comedy one and i i do like
the comedy but like what i really love
is that you know it it it's not it
doesn't teach you so much cheesy life
lessons right it's so much just just
teaches you
that you especially growing up in asian
culture it tries to teach you that you
know grades and like this the school
system isn't what defines you as a
person and i feel like a lot of people
might need to like hear some of the
things that this manga especially
especially in japan and especially in
asian culture and kind of the cherry on
top is just how [ __ ]
goofy and at the same time badass
onizuka is um i [ __ ] seeing the
antics he seeing the antics they put him
through it's just like everything is
such a treat like what my one of my
favorite one of my favorite uh scenes in
the manga which never got adapted to the
anime was like he was trying to
he was trying to teach just like this
like leader of like this uh gang to like
try try to attend school and take it
[ __ ] seriously and all that [ __ ]
and so um
this guy this this student leads him to
like this underground like fight ring or
something i can't remember the exact
setup but he's just like look
if i arm wrestle a hundred of you and
win
then you got to come to school and it's
just like this is this is so this is so
[ __ ] stupid right because it's just
like how are you going to [ __ ] arrest
arm wrestle a hundred people and then he
he beats one person he beats two persons
he he starts he starts taking on three
at a time and like he's three at a time
yeah yeah he starts taking on three
times it's the shonen mark okay and it's
just like it's the way the way that it
just kind of builds up and like
escalates is like
hilarious and badass at the same time
and it's it's something where it's not
100 serious but when it hits it [ __ ]
hits and some like it's a manga that can
really
i wouldn't say change a person but it
if you're looking for something that
affects you in the opposite way of pun
pun where it's just like wow it uses
comedy to teach you not depression yeah
it still teaches you like very important
life lessons but it it you feel
wholesome about the day i feel like i
don't want that like genre of manga is
so like beloved and known and quite you
know more common especially to a
japanese audience i feel it's slept on
in the west
probably like there are so many like
good like feel good comedy centered like
lesson type of manga that is out there
and they're all [ __ ] great yeah
because i feel like to do this type of
manga or to do cyber story it's so hard
to just not be cheesy yeah you know like
and i feel like gto is that one manga
when i'm just like
like you you see this done in any other
way and it would just be cheesy but the
way that they do in this just
it almost doesn't take itself seriously
yeah yeah exactly yeah exactly
um so yeah onizuka's like i think one of
my favorite characters in manga
for that reason